[Music]
Noor Inayat Khan was in the midst of a
desperate escape she had been in prison
for her activities as an allied spy but
with the help of a screwdriver and two
other prisoners she was back under the
Parisian Stars she began to run her
thoughts left to the whirlwind of events
that had brought her here born in Moscow
in 1914 to an Indian Muslim father and
an American mother nor was raised in a
profoundly peaceful home her parents
were Sufi pacifists who put their faith
in the power of music and compassion
they moved to Paris where Noor studied
child psychology and published
children's books but all this changed
with the advent of the Second World War
in May 1940 with the German army ready
to occupy Paris Noor and her brother
were faced with a difficult choice as
pacifist
they believe that all disputes should be
settled non-violently
but witnessing the devastation across
Europe they decided that standing on the
sidelines was not an option
traveling to England nor volunteered for
the Women's Auxiliary Air Force and
trained as a radio operator she immersed
herself in wireless operations and Morse
code unaware that she was being
monitored by a secret organization the
British Special Operations Executive was
established to sabotage the Germans in
Nazi occupied countries as a trained
radio operator who knew Paris well and
spoke fluent French nor was an
attractive recruit in her interview she
was warned that wireless operation was
some of the most dangerous work in the
intelligence field operators had to lug
a conspicuous transmitter through enemy
territory and the clandestine agency
couldn't protect her if she was caught
nor accepted her assignment immediately
while she was determined to take a
pacifist principles as far as possible
Noor had to learn the art of espionage
she learned how to contact intelligence
networks pick a lock resist
interrogation and fire a gun in June
1943 she landed in ój south of Paris and
made her way to the city armed with a
false passport a pistol and a few french
francs but her network was compromised
within a week of her deployment all her
fellow agents were arrested and Noor was
called home she convinced her
supervisors to let her stay
which meant doing the work of six radio
operators single-handedly over the
following months she tracked and
transported supplies to the French
Resistance sent reports of Nazi activity
back to London and arrange safe passage
for Allied soldiers this work was
essential to building the French
Resistance and Allied intelligence
networks and ultimately ending
protected only by her quick thinking and
charisma she frequently talked her way
out of questioning when the Gestapo
searched her on the train she gave them
a casual tour of her film projector when
an officer spotted her hanging her
aerial she chatted about her passion for
listening to music on the radio and
charmed him into helping her set up the
cable in her entire four-month tenure
her sharp wit and stealth never failed
her
but her charm had inspired lethal
jealousy in October 1943 the sister of a
colleague in love with an agent that
loved nor sold her address to the
Gestapo nor refused to give away any
information focusing instead on her
escape secret in a screwdriver away from
the guards they were able to loosen a
skylight and slip out into the night but
just as her prisoners began to run for
their lives an air-raid siren alerted
her captors nor was caught once again
and sent to a German prison then on to
Dachau concentration camp despite being
tortured deprived and isolated nor gave
nothing away in the moments before her
execution she is thought to have shouted
liberté since her heroic sacrifice nor
has been honored as a hero who waged
secret battles behind enemy lines paving
the way for freedom without ever taking
a life how was a fascist regime able to
rise to power in a democratic country
check out this lesson to track the rise
of Adolf Hitler and the Third Reich
[Music]